when I first started competitively my my
mom to really like it she didn't really
want me to like play video games really
because she's like what is this like it
makes no sense I think she still doesn't
understand she's like why are people
watching my son play video games I don't
know I actually they came out to watch
me play at MSG and obviously I got three
zero stops and now taking down Team
solomid Madison Square Garden to be your
2015 summer split champions Oh
three oh my CLG my mom knew I was losing
what a B smile total I think I was just
always really competitive player like
everything I'm every game I'm playing
I'm just super competitive so we're
League I we could just get ranked one
and then I have nothing better to other
than may get another can I just try to
get ranked one officer there is a
real-life friend of mine there's ingame
there was nothing real and he played a
lot of a legal legend video is actually
pretty good and then he invited me to
play on this team he was fighting the
only slot available on that team was
cobbling and I'm like sure why not I'll
play Tommy yeah I mostly just played a
lot of Elia and you dude like back when
I was starting out yeah hurry now going
on some piece what true Walter look at
this dude look at this guy
was that true p3 how did I get into
contact with Quantic for c9 now well I
was trying out for the team
I wanted to play ad carry or middling
and I was a neat nion wanted to play mid
or 82 so I just tried out for ad carry
because I wanted to play ad carry and I
think that was like one or two weeks and
eventually they chose me to be either
it's gonna be a triple shoulder yes it
will
this is beautiful caddy get the quarter
one more shot ninja sorry yes let's
buzzer gotta get the bench go one more
shots man tuck tail straight away there
it is beautifully done wild to well he
was the one that was caught but he
turned it around with the help from his
team
when I was first contacted by original I
didn't know what he wanted and he asked
me if I wanted to sub for this weekend's
matches and LCS and I was I was pretty
excited I was pretty stoked as my first
time like ever playing and LCS and I was
kind of excited and yeah it was really
hard for me to sleep at night before
while turtle at the back just hitting
hitting one after the other there's a
double kill frame Lauda one is Gaussian
that's gonna feed him a triple kill
am ia son that's gonna be a Quadra kill
can he get the pass to go front you 101
it's gonna be the panther careful
beautiful play wild turtle step you know
chaox
you have something to answer right now
because your replacement is doing a
fantastic job I didn't know what the
team's reaction was I was like pretty
happy I was like well I just having guys
wasn't that really cool and then yeah my
team is well they obviously didn't call
the lineage anything they were just like
chill and say yeah you did a good job
and like all right
internal the communication on the team
as I said has been seemingly going up
has this button worked on or things that
are just panning out as TSM is kind of
going back into a winning phase I don't
know that's remotely well I was kind of
always like a really troll type of
person so when it was like all our
trolling them already I was like hey
guys you got like I'm just like telling
them all the time and then yeah yeah I
was really hard for me to join their
dynamic that's my first time living by
myself so I went out and I was live with
these random guys and it was really
weird because I actually didn't know how
to do like many things I didn't know how
to make like eggs I didn't know how to
do laundry I didn't know how to do like
many separate things I had like a lot of
guys like basically helping me the
twenty thirteen worlds is the first time
I felt like there's a lot to prove like
whenever you're playing international
you have a lot more to prove I think my
my heart was like racing every game it
was like crazy generally in every single
game it was just a thing I really
enjoyed playing against international
teams to show them that na is really
good but it seems that oMG will be taken
down
TSM in Game one of their match and that
will be the game
well SK Telecom t1 after failing to beat
a Korean team for the third year in a
row Reggie and his team are heading home
early from the world championship once
again here who the [ __ ] are you I'm
Dixon already busy new Midland Peterson
just came in the team because Reginald
was looking for young talent and he
really wanted a young player that was
going to have a lot of Drive to play on
Team solomid Anderson was a best
candidate we had three chains there for
bjergsen
able to keep Dignitas in range another
change or change that Cruz is the hook a
bit chain to come in where she pulling
it from well at that time we were
changing our support and jungle player
we had like a lot of internal problems
with our team at that time Gerson wanted
to get amazing because it may
was doing really well for like well he
was kind of like an amateur player but
then he had a really good split in LCS
so we really wanted amazing and then
glebe came on the team also and then
that didn't really work out that well so
he got West Boy and I think with our
season 4 roster we had a really I think
we had a good time getting to worlds but
we ended up getting the same problem
with immortals we got a little bit too
cocky
I think overconfident and then we lost
to SK and royal and if we want one of
those matches we would have been a way
better seed and didn't have to play
something white
the team that's going to take the stage
first hasn't took the stage here yet
today they're coming in here with a
brand new jungler give it up for Team
solomid TSM is the big favorite I think
for this tournament it's gonna be 100%
decided by the synergy between Bjork Sam
Santorin going against power of evil and
kikis I just feel like TSM's uh go just
our class is there any other chains are
going to come down instead but part of
evil and they get one on two key keys
look boy it's going to go down look at
the damage to the Nexus
we must ascertain
losing at IEM San Jose was vicious and
upset I think because we didn't expect
to obviously I think we read the matter
wrongly we played like tank our comps
with no CC and like we were just playing
like a zero we had no CC until we were
like a level six we were playing like
really weak early game comps and we
ended up losing early game because they
played early doing really well I think
at MSI we didn't play very well at all
like we had pretty good screen results
but we did we weren't able to translate
it at all on stage and I think some of
our some of us like really choked under
pressure there to my even me like I
didn't play well at MSI and we just had
a lot of problems going in there so that
was a good pretty exciting event it was
nobody was more disappointed than gSN's
performance than TSM themselves because
they are a team that's very focused on
competing internationally so I femicide
we went into summer split not doing very
well we ended that split sixth place
which was pretty atrocious for TSM
because we always known for techne at
least higher than third at least and
then they brought any Keith like we had
a lot of problems this week there
starting with Keith to see if they can
improve on their winning formula I
changed it has a lot of people
scratching their heads like that most
video I didn't know what to do at the
point and I was just trying to grind
solely because I had nothing better to
do and I was basically the worst phone
into my group right now for TSM I think
that we are having problems in terms of
communication we don't need to change
out any players right now and especially
we don't need any placement TL of course
2015 League of Legends
World Championship we ended up going to
Worlds and during that time like the
cream bootcamp was pretty stressful like
we had a lot of stress like dice was
under a lot of stress like all of us
were like pretty stressed up a team
atmosphere in Paris was a not very
positive we were just having like maybe
a negative or like neutral atmosphere
like we weren't super I don't think we
were a team that time we were just
basically five people trying to work
together better and really work out that
well LGD was able to rout team solomid
in their composition find their way to
the Nexus and take down TSM TSM Sloane
victory will come last week against LGD
and they will finish it as place at one
I think after that season dyrus retires
and then I'm off the team now joins off
the team and busboy it's off the team -
and then yeah we just like [ __ ]
revamp the roster and the offseason
wildturtle made a big move leaving his
longtime TSM roster to join immortals
here and wildturtle says it wasn't an
easy walk to walk away from the team
that gave him his start in the LCS I was
looking to play like found another team
I didn't know which ones yet so I was
just like kind of becoming for you know
just trying to get like really good the
trailer for team and then it was the
team at I chose as immortals because
their team just looked really strong the
time
Walter Mooney reignover like who knew
raining over obviously had a really
great split from fnatic so I decided to
go this name and it worked out pretty
well
gets two more
another flashing gauge toward wildturtle
and Pearson gets revenge at his
ex-teammate an incredibly played series
by TSM as they pick up the last few
kills they take down the Nexus and TSM
are heading to the finals no one was
saying that TSM would win this let alone
integral leads sweep over immortals who
were seventeen and one I've actually
never been to the Air Canada Centre and
it is gonna make my first time and I'm
actually competing in it so it feels
really exhilarating to me I don't think
words can explain how I'm gonna feel
because it's just gonna be in the moment
like I played at MSG like last year like
the adrenaline I felt there was insane I
just really want to play in front of a
huge crowd again my parents my cousins
they're all gonna come watch this game
so if I lose gonna be a pretty huge
disappointment to me and my and my
siblings and everything so I really need
to win this
you